the Octagon breast my herb herb and
welcome to I would just like to start
off with the apology I feel like I
haven't done these from read about as
much as I should and I said I was gonna
do them weekly and I haven't so it's
just been a lot for me lately and I feel
like just recently I actually started to
get a hold of things in terms of
uploading videos and everything I know a
lot of already bros probably watch
videos and you're like well that video
was five-minute it probably took them
five minutes to make that I'm not saying
like my videos take the most effort they
they take minimum effort but still it is
a lot of doing it every single day as
multiple videos it's it's hard it's hard
and sometimes it can be too much and
doing a weekly show that I have to do
upon everything else it's just like it
can be a little overwhelming but but I
feel like I'm starting to have a get a
hold of things right now and I'm very
happy about that
honestly like a month ago I felt like
there's no way I'm gonna be able to keep
making videos if this goes on because
it's just too stressful for me I know
that sounds so dumb like I should have
nothing to complain about but I feel
like that at the time right now I'm
doing two videos a day and that's
perfect for me I can manage that and
then without getting stressed and it
shouldn't be something that stresses me
like it should be fun and I'm there I'm
back again I I feel so happy about that
I feel excited making these videos I
don't feel any stress with making them
it's just fun and I'm so I'm so happy
for that so yeah I guess is turning to
around about stress let me know what
makes you stressed and how you deal with
it
I just postpone everything until the
last minute and [ __ ] goes to hell that's
that's what I do
I can't
recommended so yeah I know a lot of a
lot of times I haven't uploaded Friday
because I wanna I wanted to be
spectacular I want to pee with
everything in it like that but I feel
like what's really important about these
videos is that I'm talking to you bros
cuz I feel it feels weird eh from just
uploading videos without echnology bros
in some way or another I'm trying to
give you bros a perspective from from me
of why things have changed in the
channel and stuff like that and I think
you bros will understand and accept it I
hope at least I'm pretty sure I want to
show you both something
I got this in the mail it says Guinness
World Records I thought we could open it
together isn't that cute
no yeah I thought so yeah sorry sorry
okay this is something that we did
together that I think we should all be
very proud of and that is Guinness World
Records certificate it says the most
subscribed YouTube with 12 million we're
actually 30 million now yeah
thirteen million bros i was achieved by
pewdiepie it should say by the bros as
of 20th of august 2013 officially
amazing that's what you bros are i'm but
kissing you too much here but i'm just
really it's really cool
honestly like i I never thought the the
biggest or the best and not the best but
the biggest in the world at something
that's crazy and it's all thanks to you
bro so thank you thank you we all broke
this record together I think I feel like
this is the the record with most record
perch and record person's record
Parthians in it yep English you bros
hair light it's [ __ ] noise
ah dusty myself on this creepy doll and
it's [ __ ] creepy
anyway it's Friday 13 and I'm I'm it's
creepy it's it's a creepy day okay that
had nothing to do with anything anyway
thank you folks for watching this far
like I'm doing watching I'm gonna I'm
gonna go I'll see you next week for sure
and I'm gonna announce the winners as
well there was just too many entries for
me to figure out I want to give everyone
a fair chance I hope you bros understand
stay awesome bros I Love You Man what
alright come to breakfast love you
brother